with respect to that I have to say that
less than five percent of Alzheimer
disease are genetically transmitted so
ninety-five percent are not generating
transmitted and generally speaking the
one that are generated transmitted they
tend to occur at earlier ages then a dog
is not a general rule but more often the
people who have it because of genetic
reasons that five percent of the people
population and have it at the earlier
ages but only five percent that's all
less than five percent about fighting on
that number
it's not that in China there is more
than America less on Europe there is
more or less than here there but there
are particular population that native
circumstance that could lead to dementia
and because of the habits of those does
you know population it's just there are
small groups of people for instance in
the in the Pacific they were population
they used to eat the brain of the dead
people and then they were transferring
disease which one of the symptoms of
this disease was dementia and they were
all developing dementia over there there
was a high incidence of the link just
because this habit of heating the brain
of the people that were dead and
therefore like an infection disease they
were transferring the disease for one to
end they were higher incidence of people
affected disease once this was found in
this habits were blue and we stopped
then the incidence of disease became the
same as with another populations
in general you know if you look at our
society there there is not a population
of people or you know that is more
affected by the loss of memory it is a
problem that heats with aging so
something related with the with aging
and so it's as we age we get more memory
more memory problem obviously not all
the people are evil there are some what
a better memory than others and and we
do not know why some people have a
better memory than others when we say
that that they if we keep ourselves in
our brain exercises just like a muscle
then we tend to have memory problems
less memory problems so it kind of
protective the activity of mental
activity even some people think even
physical activity it could be protected
against the memory loss the problem
problem you know the loss of memory
that's what I have to say obviously
there are diseases which are associated
the one of the most typical one is
Alzheimer disease which are associated
with the loss of memory and others but
are less relevant unless
and the characteristic symptoms of our
symptom of our semi disease which is
really whole Michael disease is the loss
of what we call short-term memory so
that's how the disease starts actually
it's people who cannot remember what
they just did just as a very short-term
memory loss and let's last for a very
very long time and publicity the memory
problem get worse and worse and only a
day late stage of Alzheimer's disease
it's when also logical memory is
affected but the major characteristic of
Alzheimer disease which is a very
widespread disease in the population
special at old age is the loss of
short-term memory